So now, the answer is infinitely many. All we needed
was these two rules and we can make infinitely many words.
This is the power that recursive definitions give us. And unlike
the previous definition which was circular, what we have now is
what we call a recursive definition. That means, we have
defined word in terms of itself but that's not the only
way we've defined word. We also have this other rule that
allows us to have a starting point. That there's one word
that we have that's defined not in terms of itself. So here's how we can
make infinitely many words using these rules. So
we can start with a non-terminal word and
let's say we choose to use the first rule. We can replace word directly with
our [UNKNOWN] and we're done, but we have
another option. We could have replaced word using
the second rule, with counter word and if we replace this word, using the
second rule, we'll end with that word
counter hippo [UNKNOWN] phobia. But that's not the
only choice, right, we could've chosen to use the first rule again, and then we
were to replace this word with counter-word
and so now we have counter, counter, word.
Again we have the choice of what to do with this word.
We could use the second rule, replace it with the terminal. And
then we'll have counter, counter hippo. Or we could replace it using
the first rule. And then we'll have counter, counter, counter followed by word.
So this can keep going as long as we want.
We can produce all of these words with any number of
counter, either zero, repetitions of counter one, two, three, four. As
many as we want. That means we can produce infinitely many
words. Some of them are going to be pretty hard to pronounce.
Actually, they're all pretty hard to pronounce. But, there's no limit
to the number of words that we can produce this way.
So this is what's called the recursive definition and the important
thing that it has is two parts. It has a base case which is here.
That's the stopping condition. That's something that says
we have at least one word that we
can define already. That we don't need to define in terms of word. And it has
the recursive case that says we can define a word in terms of another word. And
if we combine those two, well now we
have a definition that can make infinitely many words.